attend is popularly known as a home of
champions not only does this small town
boast of producing some of Kenya's
greatest athletes thousands of others
from around the world come here to train
because of its high altitude but in
recent years Kenya's prominent image in
the world of athletics has been tainted
by doping allegations we talked to
athletes who admitted to doping and told
us it's common practice this Rana asked
us not to reveal his identity he said he
felt under pressure to succeed here he's
filmed receiving an injection while
training for a big race I know doping is
bad but as run as we have to support our
families through whatever means the
first time I went for a race I lost and
that prompted me to check the risk
because this is my livelihood
athletes we talked to said it's quite
easy to get EPO in many pharmacies it's
a controlled drug mainly used for anemic
patients back to the right price doctors
nurses and pharmacists provided for
runners these pharmacists who also asked
to keep his identity hidden SARS runners
who give him a cut from their earnings
we sent him to buy this dose of EPO
which he did within hours they are
desperate that leads personally have
given six at least we also met as bulky
prop one of dozens of athletes banned by
the world anti-doping agency he's won
three World Championship titles but
tested positive for using EPO keep rope
maintains his innocence it's hard in the
sciences you know which I believe there
must be an error there if it is not a
swap work or conspiracy in science error
Kenya's doping monitors say with
thousands of athletes and stretched
resources keeping checks on everyone has
been a challenge we need to clean up all
across even at the society level so that
the ethical values of good competition
the spirit of spots where I compete the
divine I don't win I'm still happy that
I competed I ran the race I might have
been number hundred
but I finished the half marathon that is
the spirit we want to improve this is a
lucrative sport and some of those we
talked to say as long as this corruption
and Ranas willing to risk everything to
make money carbon cheating will always
be difficult
Catherine's on al-jazeera attend